[Music]
hello everyone so we'll continue our
discussion of the mathematical
preliminaries chapter
and in the previous part of the lecture
we had been discussing about the dot
product
or the scalar product and we had seen if
we take a quick look back
that a transpose b that is what is
that is what was giving us the matrix
representation of the
dot product now instead of the transpose
being present
over the a suppose we take the transpose
here then what happens okay so this is
a curiosity we'll try to answer and in
the process
we'll learn about something very very
important so that is the
agenda for this part of the lecture
okay so
we have the a vector the matrix
representation of that
and the b vector the matrix
representation of that
but now we take the transpose here so
what we are basically doing
is considering
in an explicit fashion this thing
now you note that as far as the
order of the matrix multiplications is
concerned the the order of the rows and
columns this is perfectly fine okay this
is a valid
matrix multiplication
so if we actually carry out this mat
this matrix multiplication what we'll
obtain
uh is
a1 b1 a1 b2
a1 b3
a2 b1 a2 b2
a2b3 a3b1
a3b2 and finally a3
b3
so we obtained this three by three
matrix
all right now uh
how many elements are present here we
have three into three equal to nine
elements
so this set of nine elements packed in
this particular fashion in the matrix
representation in the three by three
stack
that can be represented in the index
notation in very short
as a i b j
so you see what i'm doing here is
uh so this i there are three possible
choices here and this j this has three
possible choices here
together that three into three is giving
me the nine elements that should be
present here
okay furthermore you note that
in this particular term this particular
combination
there is no repeated index neither i is
repeated
nor j is repeated furthermore
there are two free indices
so that indicates by our rules of index
notation
that this entity it is a tensor
of order two
it is a tensor of order two
okay so individually the
a i was a tensor of order one and this
bj was a tensor of order 1 but together
they are making up
a tensor of order 2 to this kind of an
operation
which is which is this this kind of a
matrix multiplication
but this is just the matrix
representation what about the compact
notation of this
so whatever we have obtained okay so
this is certainly not the dot product
okay because had it been the dot product
would have ended up with a scalar
quantity so whatever this is this is
something new
and that new entity that is represented
in the compact notation so this is the
equivalent symbol i am using here
that in the compact notation is
represented
by this kind of the symbol let me just
draw this properly
so writing this properly this is like
this okay so
there is a circle and a cross is
embedded within it
please note that this is not the cross
product i repeat
this is not the cross product which you
are more familiar with
from your high school high school
studies
so this is this is what is referred to
as the outer product or the dietic
product
outer product or sometimes referred to
as the dietic product
okay so this is a completely new kind of
operation
that you have learned here and this
this this entire thing it certainly
represents a tensor of order two
okay now uh
what about uh
what about the question that uh
that instead of this a diadic product
with b
we considered b diadic product with a
what about them
well you have to note that if you
actually carry out the operations
like this fashion okay so for
for b direct product with a
you would be writing the b here and the
a here with the transpose
and if you actually carry out the
multiplications
you will note that this thing
it is not equal to
this okay in fact
what you will obtain is that in terms of
the matrix representation what you will
obtain
is that this entity
the matrix representation of this
is going to be the transpose of the
matrix representation of this you can
actually check it out
okay i'm not going to spend any more
time on writing this out explicitly but
you can actually verify this
all right now we have been talking about
the
outer product or the dietic product
between two vectors
okay but this kind of a outer product or
diet product
may very well be
done by considering a second order
tensor itself
and another uh another vector or another
even even another tensor
okay so suppose we we consider
a second order tensor like this
so please note that when i am writing
two tildes in
uh so beneath this capital letter t
this is representing a second order
tensor okay i am not writing this
explicitly
so this is a second order tensor and
when i take
the dynamic product of that with some
vector quantity or make that entity like
this
the result of this is going to be
some kind of a third order tensor
so the three tildes beneath it it
represent it represents a third order
tensor
so maybe better to write here
that this is
second order this is
first order
and this thing is third order
so you see one important lesson to learn
here
is that if we just go back to the
previous page when we were doing the
outer product of the direct product
between two vectors
the resulting entity it
resulted in something in a tensor
which had a higher order than each of
the individual entities
so individually a and b were each of
them was
a tensor of order one but the resulting
entity was a tensor of order two
so uh the the net of the net result of
this diatic product
is to sum up the order of the tenses so
that idea is consistent here also so
here it is
a tensor of order two and it's a tensor
of uh order one here
the dynamic product it results in an
entity of tensor of order three so two
plus one here it is
three okay now the natural question
arises
that uh so we have this kind of an
operation where the
uh where the operation is increasing
uh so to speak the the order of the
tensor okay
what about the reverse thing what about
the reverse thing that is there such an
operation
where the resulting
entity would be a tensor of a lower
order
okay so we have already come across this
in the familiar form of the dot product
but now we are going to study it
in a more general fashion so
that general terminology is
what is referred to as contraction
so this is the new topic
contraction so
let us see what this contraction is
actually meaning uh by considering
uh by considering let's say
uh a
so let let me write this down that the
dot product itself is a special case
is a special case
of contraction
but what exactly is going on here so
you see we had
this a i and this bj here
okay so let us say that these are two
separate vectors
and when we are taking the dot product
we are taking
basically the uh
we are replacing ultimately the the
the index here so either we are
replacing the i by the j
or the j by the i okay so
so this so so this is considered
separately here
okay so there is no operation going on
here between these two
so the contraction
through the process of contraction
what i'm getting is either a i b
i or
[Music]
aj bj so basically i am
uh equating two indices so
this is about two vectors which you are
very familiar with the dot product uh
is between the vectors but what up what
if we
we considered a case like this that we
consider a second order tensor and we
considered a vector
so suppose we have
t i j and separately let's say we have
v k okay
so whatever i have written here that is
exactly this thing so
so you can understand that
this is basically t i j
okay so this is t i j uh
the tensor uh the the diet the outer
product or the
diet product with the v k
okay so this is t i j v k
and although i have written it
separately to
uh so i i do not intend to write any
uh any symbol for the diary product here
so you understand that this
entire entity this tij
vk that is what is represented
by this compact notation okay but now
what i want to do is i am considering
these two things separately
and now i want to carry out the
contraction
but unlike the dot product
i can ask the question first that what
happens if i
if i make this j equal to this k
or what happens if i make this i
equal to this k we'll consider these two
different options
so first of all t i j
v j or equivalently
t i k v k
absolutely the same thing so basically
what we are doing is
we are setting j equal to k here
and here next if i do t
uh i j t
uh sorry uh this should be uh the i
right so or this is
p a j v k
so where we are setting i is equal to
a now
the first question which we must be very
careful about is that
are they is this one the same as this
the answer is no okay the answer is no
and we can see this
very clearly uh if we
consider them in an exclusive fashion so
we'll write this down in an explicit way
in the next page
so t i k v k
let us let us write this down explicitly
so this is like
t i 1
v 1 plus t
i 2 v 2
plus t i three v3
now you note that this term
here this there is only one free index
here there is only one free index
and here there is only one free index
and here also on the left hand side
this k was a dummy index a repeated
index and the only free index was this i
so in terms of the consistency of the
order of the tenses the left hand side
is very much
consistent with the right hand side what
you have expanded out
and what we can do is
we can write this out in the in the
explicit form
of the matrix notation like this
so this is for setting i equal to 1 what
we have is t 1 1 v
1 plus t 1 2 v
2 plus t 1 3
v 3 next we have p 2 1 v
1 plus e 2 2 v
2 plus e 2 3 v 3
and finally we have t 3 1 v 1 plus t
3 2 v 2 plus c
3 3 p 3 so you see
here this first one is basically a
single thing
because it's plus it's a single thing
and it's a single thing so basically you
have only
three elements present here and this is
very much
a vector okay so having just three
elements or a tensor of order one
and this is very much consistent with
what we have written now next what
happens if we do the the other
alternative so if you go back to the
previous page
and we try to do this thing with this
ekg vk
or the tij vi so what happens if we do
this
so
let's let's do this in terms of the k
this is
p k j v k
so this will be
b3 and that
expanded out in the equivalent matrix
representation
would look like this t
1 1 v 1 plus t
2 1 c 2 plus t
t 1 v 3
e 1 2
v 1 plus t 2 2 v
2 plus t 3 2
v 3 and finally for the third row we
will have will replace the j by 3 so
this is t 1
3 v 1 plus t 2 3
v 2 plus t
p 3 v 3
now you compare what we have here for
this matrix representation
and what we have here for this matrix
representation so
these two things are certainly not equal
because you note
that in general will not have t12 is
equal to t21
and t13 is not equal to t31 and
certainly t2 3 is not equal to t32 that
is why this one
this one here and this one here they are
not equal
so it so the lesson learned here is that
if we go back to this previous thing so
this
option here and this option here they
are not equal
okay so these two things they are not
equal
okay so it does make a difference on
which index
you are carrying out the contraction it
it really makes a huge difference
all right
now
[Music]
what i would like to point out here is
that uh
between these two choices uh when we
obtain these two things
uh what do they what do they uh
how are they denoted in the in the
shortened matrix notation
so you quickly note down here that this
e i k v k in the shortened matrix
notation
it would look something like this
but we have the t here but we need a
transpose here
sorry the t
here and we have the v here so
it's like this however
this one the tkj vk
that
can be represented with a transpose
okay so you can actually verify by
writing the
the t vector and the t second order
tensor
in terms of a three into three matrix
and
take the transpose of that and then
multiply with the v
and you will end up with this particular
thing
you can actually verify these two things
in fact i
i strongly suggest that you actually
carry out these
calculations on a piece of paper it'll
take you just
just a minute or two and you can
convince yourself that this is true
now uh just like we have been carrying
out the contractions over two vectors
and over a second ordered tensor and a
vector
it is very much possible to carry out
these contractions over higher order
tenses
okay and when we do that the equivalent
matrix representation
or or the compact notation involving the
transposes can get a little bit
confusing
so in the next part of the lecture what
we'll do
is to see a very easy way of obtaining
these equivalent representations so
before we end all of this what i would
like to point out
is that this is the matrix
representation
so equivalently the compact notation for
this
would be simply
this and you note
that just like we have the dot
symbol representing the scalar product
between two vectors so also here
this dot is representing the contraction
between the second order tensor and the
vector
let us not call this the dot product
here
because our familiar
intuition with the dot product is that
it results in a scalar quantity
but here you note that because we are
starting out with a second order tensor
and
vector the resulting entity because of
the contraction is certainly one ordered
less
so it is certainly an order
uh certainly a tensor of lower order
but it is it is not a scalar so this
thing is certainly not a skeleton in
fact it's a
vector uh similarly here
you have the second order tensor the
transpose of that
and then the contraction with the
vector okay so uh from
now on we would prefer to call this kind
of a symbol
uh as a as the contraction symbol
instead of the dot product of course if
we have two vector quantities then
certainly we can call this a dot product
okay
uh so these things will be extremely
useful
especially in the chapter on on the
analysis of
stress all right so with this we'll
close this part of the discussion
and continue in the next class all right
thank you very much